you can go to the Tampa Bay Times with
the illustration about how much real
estate they own and it is the is the
what is the vision is the vision to be a
country is the vision to be its own
Society because this is Tampa Bay Times
okay I mean it doesn't get worse than
your own local paper writing about you
right and it says clear takeover how
Scientology it's downtown Clearwater
footprint in three years okay so go for
it this is in three years not 50 years
three years go for it and okay so that's
one okay go up
then it grows into couple right there
they keep buying picking up keep going
keep going
they keep buying up all the real estate
keep going
keep going
keep they're buying all that real estate
keep going
keep going
keep going timeline
keep going
that's all that's left that's all that's
left in that Community they've bought
pretty much every single piece of land
and property
in Clearwater so what is the vision what
is is his solution to say I think
internationally we can have momentum
because people are starting to figure
this out so let's have a massive
community that we build it here similar
to let's just say certain churches did
it in you know in Salt Lake City or some
churches that the Vatican is that is
that kind of what his strategy is what's
the vision of the church okay there's a
few answers to this one yes it is the
vision that Clearwater and Scientology
announced this in 2000 I think it was to
become the first Scientology city on
earth Clearwater and this is pursuant to
Hubbard's objective of bringing the
governments and Society into complete
compliance with the aims and policies of
Scientology
this is what he said
Clearwater is the microcosm of a bigger
um thrust of Scientology under the
control of David muskavich and this goes
back also in part to the fact that
Scientology is tax-exempt because you
cannot as an exempt organization
accumulate liquid wealth and not spend
it on anything because the theory of
exemption is that you are providing
services that the government would
otherwise have to provide so you have to
provide some sort of a public benefit if
you're just raking in millions tens of
millions hundreds of millions dollars
and not doing anything with it
you're outside of the the scope of what
should be an exempt organization but if
you are purchasing property to provide
service to your congregation
the IRS is prohibited
effectively from looking behind any of
those transactions and going well you
don't really need that building you
don't really need this one because that
would be making uh you know
impermissible under the the First
Amendment
encroachment of government into the
policies and practices of a religion so
the genius of this is
Scientology under muscavige has bought
hundreds and hundreds of millions of
dollars worth of property
that remains on the the asset sheet of
Scientology so it's not like
disappearing anywhere because ultimately
what reflects according to Hubbard the
success of Scientology is its total
assets
that is the measure of success of
Scientology the total assets Cash Gold
bank accounts Properties Real Property
all of that accumulated is kept track of
to the dollar every single week
and these property assets have become
like the new
Scientology has become a real estate
Empire and clear water is sort of the
as Scientology shrinks in numbers and
influence around the world which is
certainly happening and that is
happening primarily due to the internet
and the proliferation of media coverage
that has now occurred about what really
goes on in Scientology it is
consolidating at its quote spiritual
headquarters in Clearwater Florida and
Tracy McManus the reporter at the Tampa
Bay times has been doing a magnificent
job of tracking exactly what's going on
because a lot of those properties are
being purchased Now by
Shady llc's that are really just
Scientology fronts or scientologists who
are controlled by if you're a
Scientologist in downtown Clearwater and
you buy a property and Scientology David
miscavage tells you okay sell to us
you're selling it so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here